[Music]
welcome to CBS this morning we have some
breaking news the great thing about
morning television is we get the first
crack at the news with us now from the
shooting scenes how urgent of a threat
is Isis so to be clear mr. Trump has no
financial relationships with any Russian
oligarchs but that's what he said that's
what I said that's obviously what about
position is do you think you're the last
Dalai Lama
see what you learned on TV right now the
busiest Amtrak quarter in the country
shut down could a cure for treat any
disease it's also really exciting we're
in the historic East Room of the White
House it really is incredible to be here
this morning in there now a story you
will see only on CBS this morning my
head around the fact that a 27 year old
mother is firing off as many rounds like
she does this is a town that is still in
shock really still grieving over the
deaths of 28 people in the middle of all
the fear and panic people stepped up to
help one another as a journalist I feel
an incredible responsibility because
there's a trust factor were you scared
mm-hmm what were you thinking we are
standing just in front of Houston's main
evacuation center being a journalist is
like having a front-row seat to history
the man who targeted you is now the head
of the Taliban does that scare you
I'm not scared of the thyroid line you
believe president Trump's greatest
diplomatic achievement will be what
happens here on the Korean
who's driving the agenda on tax reform
is at the White House the Trump tax plan
and the Ryan tax plan is different you
done your homework Uncas could you
convince Putin to get Assad to step
aside do you believe that climate change
is the number one threat to the world
today no we only have one planet and so
we've got to get this way here are 10
reasons I love Nora brains values family
athleticism curiosity humor ambition
friendship style and I say last but not
least a great beauty inside and out
[Music]
it's truly been the best job I have
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]